- Hey Saf.
- What's up Steven?
- How's it going?
- Just looking at pictures of babies.
- I just got this amazing
opportunity to go on a
Worth It episode and do
Cheap Versus Expensive Dates.
- Cool.
- Yeah, but my girlfriend
is right now in Ohio
so she can't do it.
- So you want me and Tyler to do it.
- Yes, I would love that.
- Only for you Steven.
- Yes!
Pack your bags.
- Pack my bags, are we going to Vegas?
- No, we're not going to Vegas.
No Vegas.
- Today we're going to try
out three different dates
at three drastically
different price-points
and we're gonna see which one is
the most worth it at its price.
Unfortunately my girlfriend
is currently in Ohio.
- Okay.
- RIP (laughs).
- She's not dead.
So I thought who better to
bring on these dates than
my favorite couple of Buzzfeed?
- [Tyler] Thank you.
- Wait, so you're not coming with us?
We want you to be there.
- How about I'll film it?
- I think it sounds great
cause we're going all
the way to Vegas.
- We're not going to Vegas.
- We're going to Vegas baby.
- We're not doing that.
- Just say it's Vegas baby.
- Vegas, that's it.
- All right, we're here
at Dockweiler Beach,
I brought my friends
Saf and Tyler to enjoy
the beautiful day.
I packed them a nice lunch.
The coolest thing about
the beach is that you can
do so many different things.
Literally the world is your
oyster, ha ha, on the beach.
- Yay, woo!
Do you want your canvas bag?
- It's so nice out here.
- It is amazing.
Do you want to set up our blanket babe.
(laughing)
- Ty!
Let's see what Steven packed us.
- Yeah.
- For lunch.
- [Tyler] Love you baby.
- [Safiya] I love you.
(laughing)
I love the beach, I've
always been into the beach.
- I love the beach, yeah.
- We're kind of like water peeps.
- Not only do I love the beach,
but it's a beautiful day.
It's so cathartic, like
with the smell, the wind.
- It's just relaxing.
Well obviously living in
LA you're never too far
from the beach so it's always
like kind of an easy option.
Getting to the beach
maybe it's like gas costs,
that's about it.
- There's like this great
dynamic where like there's
gonna be restaurants and
ice cream and a place where
you can get something to
drink close by, right?
- Tyler's a cheap date.
What's happening?
- We're napping.
- How about that beach though?
- It was fantastic.
- It was fun.
- And what was your favorite part of that?
- Well I took a nice little nap.
- Yeah, Tyler was asleep.
- Really relaxing.
- I feel like the inner
child inside of me comes out
at the beach.
- Date fact, did you know
that date palms can take
up to four to eight years
before bearing fruit?
- So it's a long incubation period.
- Yeah, it's like dating
somebody in real life.
- It takes four to eight
years to have babies?
- You said it not me.
- What, it actually takes
a lot less time than that.
- This date is a middle priced date.
- Would you say it's
more of a wooing date?
- It's more of a get to know you date.
We're gonna go to a painting class.
- Oooo, Safiya has never
gone painting with me
so actually this is a perfect activity
for us to try together.
- We're already two years
in so it's not like,
"Oh wow, bad at painting, deal breaker."
- I'm Ann Bridges and
we're in my studio today.
The class that we're doing today is called
Introduction to Acrylic Painting.
Aprons.
- Thank you.
- It's been awhile since
I've worn an apron.
- I want to start by saying the
class is supposed to be fun.
You can have a little bit
of pressure if you come to
an art class about doing
it perfectly and the point
is to be here and just
relax for two hours.
I start out by just
talking a little bit about
how color works in the
light and in the shadow
and then I put a still
life up and just show
them step-by-step on how to start,
how to get color in and how to finish.
This makes a really unique
day, it's really lighthearted.
I think Safiya and Tyler
are going to do great.
- I'm not great at painting
but it's just really fun,
especially when there's no
expectations for perfection.
Now what I'm worried about
is trying to achieve painting
that because like, I know I can't.
- [Ann] Oh, you're going
to be so surprised.
(classical music)
That's beautiful Safiya, that's perfect.
- [Safiya] My inner
overachiever's like, "Thank you."
- I'm hearing these good
compliments for Safiya
so I'm really excited to see
what she's done over there.
- [Ann] You're doing great too.
- Well I've actually
consciously been holding
off from looking at
Safiya's until this point
so why don't we turn each other's over
and show.
One.
- Two.
- Three.
- Wow.
- Yours is good.
- Yours is so cute.
- Does mine looks like
a five year old did it?
- No it doesn't, I think yours is great.
- The colors are good actually.
- The colors are great.
- Good painting sweetie.
- Good job.
Sorry, I had lipstick on, is that gross?
- Nnnn.
- Thank you so much, this was so fun.
- We had a great arts and crafts find,
it like took me right back
into like my school days,
and I loved it.
- You both did beautifully.
- I thought it was really fun,
I actually really liked it.
- Yeah.
- It was a very innocent
and sweet date and it made
me want to pinch your cheeks.
I just hit your face, I'm sorry.
- Date fact.
43% of singles had fallen
in love with somebody
that they were not initially attracted to.
- That sounds familiar.
- That sounds about right.
- For her, I was always
coo coo for Safi pops.
- Tyler and I were friends
for awhile before we
started dating so I think
that we grew into it.
- And now finally the most
expensive, most luxurious date.
Tyler, me and Saf are
going to take you on a
romantic helicopter
ride across Los Angeles.
- What?
- Yeah.
- A helicopter ride.
- This is an awesome way to close the day.
- Spoiler alert, I am afraid of heights.
- But Steven, you can't leave us now.
- My name is Venida and
I'm the helicopter pilot
here and I'll be taking Tyler
and Safiya on a tour tonight.
- I think the coolest part
about this date is that
it's something that we
never really get to do
and we have barely ever done before.
- Or even thought of doing.
- [Anida] We roll em up and
we bring him to the hanger.
There is a cabana here
that overlooks the airport.
- [Safiya] Oh wow, now this
is like a rain forest cafe.
- [Anida] So you can see
all the airplanes coming in
and out of here and they get
a couple roses, champagne,
a couple french pastries
so it's a very intimate
thing for 45 minutes
they do before the tour.
- It's so much harder to eat that way.
- Then I start walking
them out to the helicopter,
we take a couple pictures
in front of the helicopter.
I give them the safety
briefing, I load them up
and then we're on our
way to whatever route
that they chose for the night.
What's great is that it's different
and you get to see the city
in a different perspective
that most people get to in their lifetime.
- I mean, I think it will
be fun, I think there
will be some adrenaline and I think
Steven might cry, and I think that it's
going to be a great time.
- Yeah, this date is going
to be that much better
cause Steven's going to be
up there with us, right?
- Great tour over Van
Nuys, over Topanga Canyon.
We saw Will Smith's house.
- That was the highlight, I
mean besides being with her.
- [Safiya] But then we got
to be like right over sort of
the ocean like right outside of Malibu
and that was so cool.
- And this is places we've been to a lot.
We've driven up and down
that Malibu PCH right there
and like seeing it from this
angle was just incredible.
- I like to imagine a little
bit like Jasmine in Aladdin
like magic carpet ride, but
just with Steven and Vanida
there as well.
- It was really fun to
do because it's more just
like we get to look at
stuff and hang out rather
than try to schmooze.
- That said, again, even
if you were early on a date
and you held off the romantic
time till afterwards,
it's a perfect date.
- Absolutely.
- Great date.
- Romance, that's the
definition of it right there.
- Guys we did it.
Tripod went on three
dates, except it was mostly
for you guys.
- It was a little bit for you.
- It was a tripod.
- So obviously all of these
date options were amazing
but if you had to choose
one, which date did you
feel like was the most worth it.
- I thought the helicopter
date was so cool
and I'm so glad we got to
do it but it just isn't
something that I would
see us doing on the reg.
I liked the painting date
just cause it was a little
bit out of something we usually do.
We don't usually like plan
little activities like
that together.
- I think that the
beach date was the best.
Really simple, it really
let us be able to talk.
- I do wanna say thank you to you guys for
testing these dates out for me.
- We had a good time.
- We need to call upon the
third wheel and be like,
"Hey, listen, we're trying
to go to this place,
"I don't know if you've
heard of it, Vegas,
the third leg of the tri-pod.
- Yes, confirmed, next
episode of Safiya, Tyler
and Steven in Vegas baby.
- Vegas baby.
- Confirmed.